there's really like three guys in the
dating Market three archetypes so
there's one we're going to go and make
them the cell phone cuz that's the most
valuable thing I'm going to use the cell
phone guys are the the top Guys these
are going to represent the men that
these guys really don't have to do much
to get late like first date most women
are giving it to them second date right
they don't even really have to take
chicks on date and these are the men
that are going to have a really hard
time settling down because they've seen
the worst side of Fe male nature they've
seen the the good girls come on to them
they've seen the really like they're the
guys that have screwed a lot of your
wives